one thing I've heard from a few people
is oh I would I would start a business
but I don't want to be a Salesman what's
what's going on there impossible
impossible if you're going to start a
business you are going to be a
salesperson otherwise your business
isn't going to be around for very long
everybody selling something product
service
experience you know it's just one of
those things you you go to
Disney you go to a Disney park and you
get off a ride
nine times out of 10 when you get off
that ride and you want to go out into
the main street of the park again you
got to walk through a souvenir or gift
shop of some variety they're selling you
it's very subtle it's passive but
they're selling you and the vast
majority and to use just to stick with
Disney by the way I'm a big Disney fan
I'm a dad I got four kids two are adults
now but it's tough to be a parent and
not you know love Disney right and I
love Disney I think they're a great
company but boy do they not how to sell
Disney are one of the best companies on
the planet to sell and there's just no
way that you can start you can start
something not worry about making money
and not make money but you can't call
that a business because a business makes
money right you can call it a hobby I've
got enough Hobbies I prune bonsai trees
that's a great hobby I love my bonsai I
play with Lego sets with my kids that's
a hobby I collect Pokemon cards that's a
hobby too right but none of those things
make me money well actually probably
sold a few Pokemon cards before but like
other than that my business is my
business where I make my real money and
so I I don't think it's possible to
start a business and not be involved in
sales particularly initially anyway you
know what did you mean when you said
that creating content is selling well
because when you publish that piece of
content you're selling somebody on
either a your opinion or B the ability
of you being able to help them in some
capacity with the content that you've
created and published right so I mean if
we use you as an example and what you do
on your YouTube channels you are helping
people to live a more productive a more
fulfilling more joy filled life that's
your jam that's a good phrase yes we
should still that yeah let's write that
down um I I know where to send the the
invoice that abely um but no I mean you
know and and and that that's your jam
that's what you're all about and you
create content every single week that
you put out to an audience that's
growing um over you know every single
month your audience gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger why because
you're selling them on the idea on how
you can either educate entertain or
Inspire them and every single piece of
content that we create the one of those
three things right
also every single time you hit publish
on a YouTube video or publish on a
podcast or publish on a blog post every
single time you do that you're creating
a business asset that will live for 247
365 days a year to help you grow your
business it's an asset is what that is
and it's a money-making asset as well
because it only takes one person finding
a video that you published two years ago
to fall in love with what you're all
about they then and buy your book they
then go and buy one of your courses and
before you know what's happening as and
when you potentially decide to do it
you've opened up your Mastermind it's 50
Grand a year to be a part of it and
they've jumped on board all because of
one YouTube video that they found
randomly because that's a piece of
content and you sold them you sold them
on why Ali is so great and why they need
to follow you yeah I always think of
think think of videos as as as assets as
well it's like you know we've we've made
a few videos where like one of our
videos it's got like 10 10 million views
even just on AdSense income alone that
video is made over £100,000 it's just
utterly ridiculous because to make
£100,000 from property you would have to
either flip a property buy at auction do
a ton of work on it and then flip
it for 100k or you're you've got like 30
years worth of yield to get to 100K in
property as an and yet this video that
took half an hour of planning an hour of
filming and someone else a few hours of
editing has turned into into this
ridiculously value asset and over time
over the last 6 years we've made 580 or
so videos just on the main YouTube
channel all of which are directly
passive income generating assets but
they're also generating you know
tomorrow someone could watch a video I
made six years ago because they're
applying to med school and be like oh I
want to check out and check out more of
this guy the algorithm is helping as
well because often people don't even
have to make an active choice to watch
more of my stuff but if they've watched
it and the algorithm knows that they
watched enough of it to register as an
interested viewer it will surface more
of it to them and it's just this magical
like virtual cycle that just yeah yeah
yeah and now you know when when we look
at like monetization of a personal brand
you know you've got things like courses
and coaching and Consulting and speaking
and writing books and masterminds and in
your case because you're creating
content on a regular basis that's going
out to a mass audience you've got things
like sponsorship Google ads or rather uh
what do you call it YouTube ads AdSense
you know all that kind of stuff like
those things like the sponsors that are
jumping on board now are going
after putting something in front of your
audience as it is right now but what you
the sponsors and even your audience
members have to understand and really
appreciate is that those sponsors as
great as they're going to be and as
helpful as they're going to be to your
current audience are only here because
you've busted your
ass doing what you do every single day
to create all those manyi assets that
are ultimately going to mean that they
want to part with money to get in front
of your audience so that's something
that you need to celebrate as a content
creator and as a personal brand as well
this is not in any way shape or form
and like this is not out of the blue
like this isn't something that's just
come out of nowhere this has been slowly
but surely having a compound effect on
your following and on your influence as
a personal brand for a long time um and
the company to end up and sponsor this
show or any other show for that matter
they um they're getting the benefit of
all that hard work hey friends thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye-bye